i've been trying to get internet at my
house since i moved here
um it's been years and years and i have
used all the resources i can
we've wasted billions of dollars and
we've wasted time the pandemic has
really shown that broadband is
just like electricity and just like
water you really need it these days to
survive
as the school year begins cobit 19 has
again highlighted a digital divide
millions of americans in rural areas
nationwide are struggling to connect to
the internet
so why is the country's broadband
infrastructure still not reliably
connecting rural communities
the recent bankruptcy of one of the
largest rural internet providers
frontier communications helps reveal why
it's unclear exactly how many people in
america lack a high-speed internet
connection
the official estimate from the federal
communications commission is 21 million
people
but others estimate it to be double that
a recent study by microsoft says
if you include people who have a
connection that's slow or unreliable the
figure is more like 157 million people
or roughly half of the u.s population
eva melinson and her husband and three
kids have tried all they can to get
internet access in sissonville west
virginia
though frontier is one of the only
providers in the area
it's not even an option for their house
we had wild blue
satellite we had hughes net satellite
then we gave up on satellite because if
it rained or snowed
it didn't work we switched to the cell
phone booster
and we've tried to get regular internet
at the house sudden link or frontier you
know they're just
they won't come up to our house most
days eva drives three miles from her
house to this mobile home that her
sister-in-law sarah rents that gets
faster internet from suddenlink
another west virginia provider sarah's
house gets frontier but it's too slow
and just up the hill eva's house gets
neither frontier nor suddenly
the state is a patchwork of complicated
unreliable options like these i've been
coming since we
all got sent home for covid and the
schools got shut down it's like the end
of march
so we've been coming here since then to
kind of take advantage of what internet
we can get here
on top of her full-time job eva is
helping teach her kids and neighbors
kids as they start the school year with
online classes
while broadband internet has improved
for many across the country
for people like eva's family and
neighbors makeshift options like this
mobile home have become the best
solution many experts
including former fcc chairman tom
wheeler say one problem
is that the federal government doesn't
treat broadband like a public utility
instead it's largely relied on the
internet industry to regulate itself
and provide service and select areas at
a range of prices
dating back before the internet even
existed the fcc has had a program where
it collects money from
telephone users bills and rededicates
that money to make sure that
rural areas are served this is very
similar to how
the us extended electricity to rural
areas
the fcc has taken that money in the
modern age and repurposed it to try to
extend broadband
to communities across the country
they've thrown a lot of money at this
problem there are
a lot of parts of this country that
still aren't getting help
frontier might not be a household name
like att or comcast
but it's one of the largest internet
providers in the country and in rural
areas in minnesota or in west virginia
like where eva's family lives
they can be one of the only internet
options five years ago
frontier was awarded over a billion
dollars from the federal communications
commission to expand their networks in
rural areas
earlier this year the company told the
fcc it was not meeting its target
requirements in numerous states
then back in april at the start of the
coronavirus pandemic
frontier filed for bankruptcy what was
interesting about that bankruptcy
is they had to disclose a lot of
information that we don't usually get
frontier's bankruptcy documents offer a
window into why rural parts of the u.s
and particularly states like west
virginia
lag behind much of the developed world
and providing reliable internet
sec filings frontier provided to
bondholders show the company chronically
under-invested in faster broadband
infrastructure like fiber optics
only 21 of frontier service area is
served by fiber
after more than a decade of promised
upgrades in a statement
frontier said the available speed
depends on multiple variables
including especially in rural areas the
distance that the customer's location is
from our internet equipment
the documents also reveal why they
weren't required to invest in upgrades
across the country more than one and a
half million homes have only one choice
for internet access
frontier for another 11.3 million homes
there are only two options for
high-speed internet service the company
describes this as a strong competitive
position
frontier says the company offers service
in many of the most rural areas of the
country
places that our competitors largely
choose not to serve because these rural
areas
often have challenging terrain are more
sparsely populated
and are the most expensive to serve
whether you're frontier or whether
you're verizon
why would you be putting money into west
virginia when every dollar you put into
west virginia
is going to return a lot less than
dollars that you put into
pittsburgh or put into you know a major
urban area
eva's sister-in-law sarah works from
home and started renting the mobile home
for 600
a month after struggling for years with
slow internet speeds from frontier at
her house
this is the frontier internet and we're
going to do
a speed dust it's the only option she
has at home
and she still pays 130 dollars for both
phone and internet services
despite her efforts to find an
alternative i've
filed fcc complaints i've contacted the
governor's office
i've called people i've signed petitions
i've done
everything that there has been to to do
something about improving it
i i've participated in because i
i depend on the internet the fcc's
chairman ajit pai
says his number one priority has been
closing the digital divide
there's still many millions of americans
who don't have access at all or have
insufficient competition
we want to change that to make sure that
every american has what i call digital
opportunity the agency has handed out
billions of dollars in funding and
subsidies to improve rural broadband
access
with another 16 billion slated to be
auctioned in october
the data that the us has about broadband
networks isn't really
great and the government doesn't have a
good idea where broadband
is and where it isn't so if a rural
carrier
builds broadband across a certain county
it can get credit for
serving that entire area when in fact it
only serves
parts of the area and this ends up
serving some homes while leaving others
behind
the fcc says it's fixing the maps but
chairman pai says the funding can't wait
we see states that are still making
policy
based on what the cable and telephone
companies the big cable and telephone
companies tell them
but we electrified the country by
recognizing that
that those business models did not work
for all of america
and west virginia is one of those places
where those models really don't work
the kids go to school online you know
and they're
just so many different things you can
experience online that they don't
have the ability to do right now and
it's a shame i am
very lucky that i can rent this place
but i mean that's not a common
occurrence you know
and i don't think that you should be
forced to do that when you have a
perfectly good home
you know why can't we get broadband